as directors who have helmed you know a
good portion of these episodes i would
say um i i'm curious
for the both of you
um what was a moment where when you read
it in the script there was an immediate
sense of knowing visualizing how you
wanted to render it on screen whether it
was a small character moment
or like a big action set piece
um
was it instant i'm not quite sure it was
instant for us but it came like very
soon after in the car chase in 103 was
knowing that we wanted to
um stay with our characters and be in
the experience with them and
experiencing at least the first part of
that car chase
um from inside the car with that 360
revolving camera
and it might have been the case because
we'd just recently
watched
the indie movie waves and they do a
lovely
character development piece a little bit
like that and so it's very much inspired
by that but like what happens if you
choreograph the action around this
moving camera so
the action happens just in time for us
to see it at each beat and just in time
for us to come back for the for the
dialogue and keep in it and keep in the
relationship with them until kate goes
out the window and then
we break that
we also knew we wanted at some point for
them both too we wearing really bad
sweaters christmas sweaters
very important character development so
we made sure that happened
i feel like that's a crucial part of any
any kind of christmas set
any christmas set story um i love that
you brought up the episode three car
chase and that single take singing
because i think that's something that
fans have been buzzing about since it we
got a first glimpse of it and then
seeing it last week
um
for both of you what's one thing that
people might be surprised to know about
behind the scenes what goes into kind of
making a shot like that happen
so
much we actually started working on that
before we were
you know in atlanta for the shoot so
a good month and a half two months
before
uh we work with the post biz team on
starting to bring that to life like it's
it's extensive and from talking about
what's shot in new york what's not how
you do it what cameras are you know the
technical side of it and then trusting
your team to help bring that together in
the best way possible and right up until
a few weeks before we were still talking
about how to shoot it and we had some
backup options on the day if something
didn't work so it was a continually
evolving
scene uh both technically and creatively
but we feel like by the end of it when
we decide on how many arrows and how
many cars explode and what they you know
it all kind of came together but it took
a good
three to four months um
to work on that
um given this week's episode
and the i would say the florence pew of
it all um
[Music]
how difficult is it to try and kind of
go through
producing a normal episode of television
while also trying to hide a big
character reveal like that i'm assuming
it's it's
uh there's a lot of moving pieces
involved
well especially in in episode four you
don't see it coming because you haven't
you haven't had the seed so much of it i
mean we we talk about the the natasha of
it all
um in that what we call the kind of a
christmas montage where
um
kate and clint become closer
as friends than they've ever been um but
in terms of disguising it throughout you
know you've got this
person who appears on the roof in a mask
and and if if you know the comics you'll
you'll recognize kind of the lights on
the mask and so there was i'm sure there
were fans who were already going oh this
is it this is it this is it but at that
point we just have to let that action
play out and uh the reveal happens when
the reveal happens you know
um i think i have time for one more
question and and for both of you you've
worked on another fabulous show in the
great um is there anything that
surprised you in terms of similarities
between a show like that and this one
even though you know on the surface the
genres are very different
yeah i think actually one thing
this is more technical thing it's just
um the great had a lot of corridors
a lot of great walk and talks and i
think that's something that we we really
fell in love with is just keep your
characters moving and because clint and
kate are always on
a mission
it was a natural kind of inclination of
ours to keep them on the move as much as
possible and that that was something
something that came across from what we
what we enjoyed doing on the great um
and really implemented here to keep our
story uh moving that's a very technical
um
learning
tonally you know
visit the great is different in so many
ways but there's an absurdity to the
great and kind of like real human
emotion in crazy situations and that's
similar to what kate and clint are
they're real humans and then this you
know the larpers get involved and like
the tracksuit mafia are like a bit
ridiculous and also dangerous you know
and
you know in catherine's story they you
know she's a she's a woman
going through this world of of peter
where
crazy stuff can happen at any given
moment and she just has to roll with the
punches so
in in that way um you can find
connections between the two of them
for sure um that's actually all the time
i have but thank you so much for both of
you for sitting taking the time to chat
about the show it was a it's been great
so far and and i can't wait to to see
next week's and and find out how this
all continues so thank you again for
your time thanks so much